it wasn't just Luke Beasley on the
ground in Pickens South Carolina for the
Trump rally we also have these
incredible interviews done by right-wing
media including right side broadcasting
this one is maybe the sickest we've seen
a woman at the Trump rally in South
Carolina
said that Biden and others should be
taken to the train station
I I there's no way around this folks
she's talking about trains to
concentration camps
that's what this woman is talking about
and says it with no shame what should
president Trump doing day one when he
gets back in
lock them up right
a deep State take it down
train station
take him to train station
I didn't say that that's even almost too
much for Marjorie Taylor Green's
boyfriend Brian Glenn Who does these
interviews this is what Nazis say
here's a guy at the Trump rally who told
Brian Glenn Trump's trying to expose the
Deep state
and Lindsey Graham's part of that deep
state I'm sure first you got to expose
the Deep State and he's been working on
that and working on working on it one of
the creatures is here
[Applause]
is here Brian Glenn also unsure whether
he wants to get involved in that of
course one of the things cultists often
say when they are constantly lied to by
the cult leader is that the cult leader
is really honest
here's what this woman had to say like
people are becoming more involved rather
than they did before and a lot of
people's eyes are opening to what is
more truthful and what's not right yeah
yeah absolutely truth is a revolution
right now and that's not something that
we've had in a long time it feels good
it's refreshing to think it's refreshing
that Trump is so so so honest so so so
honest and then even interviewing an 11
year old girl who has been sadly
brainwashed with the same stuff says
Trump's the only honest guy left why are
you excited to be here what what made
you want to come out
um because I love Trump what is it that
you like about Donald Trump
he only tells the truth
the big thing right tell them the truth
scary cult stuff scary cult stuff
we've got a great bonus show for you
today sign up at joinpakman.com remember
Alex Jones hates the bonus show well the
bonus show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves as bad Howard Stern likes the
bonus show but he won't pay for it a
David Pac-Man membership costs six bucks
a month yep joinpakman.com my friends
that's the place to sign up we will see
you on the bonus show
we need to teach kids to think
critically and independently and we
aren't doing a good enough job of it I
have a book right here that teaches kids
critical thinking I wrote this book and
it's available on Amazon at
davidpackman.com book this is told
through the story of a kid detective the
idea is critical thinking thinking
independently is like solving a mystery
getting clues evaluating them thinking
through scenarios the right knows that
when kids think critically they don't
end up being Republicans when they're
adults and that's why they hate teaching
kids critical thinking this book alone
won't solve the problem but it will get
kids interested get a copy Kindle
paperback
davidpackman.com book